let's just get this [ __ ] out of the way
what's up bro
the rams niners thing
i've historically known you to be a 49er
fan me and you have had verbal arguments
about the 49ers because i'm a cardinal
fan
yeah these are on youtube somewhere okay
on my channel you probably just look we
got i just realized we have like 12
interviews over the years
so
now you're a rams fan i've been around
foreign first okay so you've been
knowing me for
my like i met your
2010 my my older my teenage adult life
you didn't know me since i was
like my youth correct
you feel me i grew up a rams fan my
father is a ranch fan
i started doing my music [ __ ] moving
around
going to the bay
we knew some people that was from la
that played on the niners that was
inviting us to the games we started
going to the games young [ __ ]
who don't got a team in l.a
going to the niner games like this is
our first
nfl game so we like [ __ ] we [ __ ] with
the niners cool for show niner game
so we was [ __ ] with the niners and we
started hanging with kaepernick and
frank gore's and michael crabtrees and
all of them uh sean golson is the one
that
brought us up there like that boom we
get in
we in with them i'm the type of dude
you feel me i support
the teams or the people that i know like
so if i got a relationship with like
russell westbrook no you used to [ __ ]
with the thunder you used to yeah
they're not for sure yeah them [ __ ] is
from the city so i'm supporting that
so that's how i got into the niners [ __ ]
but i was a rams fan first okay okay you
feel me since a kid like real football
fan team not no oh cause i know this
person i know this person you feel me
it was rams and [ __ ] chicago bulls
michael jordan that's how it all started
so um
and then i i i had to cut the niners off
when they
did the whole kaepernick [ __ ]
so i honestly don't
see how
people is still uh supporting the niners
organization after the whole kaepernick
situation happens so i'm proud and i'm
glad to say [ __ ] the 49ers i've been
saying [ __ ] the 49ers when that whole
[ __ ] happened
exactly so you want to go and you want
to bring up the past like you know
everything but you leaving [ __ ] out well
listen cause i don't understand how you
forgot about kaepernick maybe i'm angry
that your black people eliminated the
rams for black people he took a knee
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to [ __ ] with
the niners after they kicked them off
the team cutting them out the nba i
don't [ __ ] with them bro well that's
fair yes so so so now you know i'm just
a petty fan of the cardinals who's mad
that y'all [ __ ] smoked us and got us
the [ __ ] up out of here for the year
well i'm just a real [ __ ] well shout
out to the rams man yeah hello it's rams
gang now yeah who's that ben rams gang
bro okay okay come correct don't come at
all